I'm clay Benziger I worked for Bloomberg
and I work on our Hadoop infrastructure
team so I want to walk through and
explain to you some ideas that we've
come up with that we've heard to as data
gloveboxes and data drop boxes and how
they work and some analogies of where
these terms came from with that I grew
up in Colorado near the Rocky Flats
plutonium plant so it was always kind of
a specter over my childhood and that may
have had some influence I guess when
thinking about systems architecture the
nuclear controls around nuclear
materials handling is very rigorous
something that I think of software
engineers we're really thankful we
usually don't have to to have anywhere
near that much unless you work in life
critical applications but with that
there are actually some interesting
analogies we can think about for data
one of the things that right now
certainly has a lot of us and a lot of
the public saying hey I want to make
sure that things are protected safely
and so what we're looking at here is
actually a nuclear glove box
it's an isolation device to be able to
help prevent this man here from being
irradiated by the the material that he's
he's working with and in fact this is
one of the last generations that was at
the plant before they closed it down you
can see he's got robotics
you know he's able to actually have just
normal clothes on and all in all he's
he's able to be relatively relaxed
compared to to what you might think of
when handling nuclear materials that are
quite toxic and quite radioactive but
it's still worth us asking and walking
through you know what is Bloomberg B as
a lot of you guys might not know us
might not know why why do we care about
data and what you're looking at here is
the Bloomberg professional service it's
our kind of premier product and this is
why we have a lot of data that we have
to think about we were founded 37 years
ago we've got around three hundred
twenty five thousand subscribers to our
service they span the globe and with
that the really nice thing for us is
we're a relatively mid-sized company by
this point where we've got 5,000
software engineers we've got enough
software engineers that we can really
say hey we want to see the industry move
we can implement really cool stuff in
particular for data we've got now a
cadre of about a hundred plus machine
learning data scientists and engineers
and they say hey play you know we want
on your Hadoop clusters to be able to
run some really really neat analytics
but some of this data we need to protect
so that gives us some good thoughts here
we also have a very large news
organization probably a lot of folks
have seen Bloom
TV or Bloomberg News in print we
actually have more reporters than the
New York Times The Washington Post and
Chicago Tribune combined right now and
we get about 125,000 sources coming in
so just the volume of data from that
news organizations massive about a one
and a half million stories a day so you
know just the the trickle of stories is
still pretty pretty voluminous for
distributing that financial and this
information folks don't always want to
rely on the internet that could go down
so we have one of the largest private
networks in the world as well and then
with that we actually attended it to
have some very high volume data every
stock trade or offered a trade is what
we call a tick and we get a hundred
billion plus with those a day so this
stuff is very low latency and very
latency sensitive which makes our jobs
fun on the heavy per team trying to
record all those in various ways and
then of course there's just
communication from humans emails and
what we call instant Bloomberg's instant
messages coming in so all this data you
know has different sensitivity levels
and different concerns and some of it
needs to be treated very carefully I'm
sure your companies you want to protect
your customers the same and you don't
want to have to stand around like these
guys in bunny suits to protect their
data or protect you from their data here
we see how platinum was handled in a
robotic system that looks like these
folks were repairing normally there
would be no people in here and it would
just be a large a large robotic array of
storage containers so how do we do that
for data and why do we do that let's
think about some of the properties that
might be similar between radioactive
materials and data something we might
not think about terribly often so
radioactive materials can be harmful to
people in small quantities you know we
think about disasters unfortunately
Chernobyl and fishy , and you know we
can't see a lot of this even when we're
on the periphery there's still
biological effects but trying to
quantify that can be challenging there's
an incredibly long hazard life for
plutonium it's atonium 239 that isotope
is a 24,000 year half-life so you know
most of us won't really see that
degrading at any reasonable quantity and
so kind of one of the the prevailing
thoughts is we should probably isolate
these things to prevent their spread you
know we don't want to track them on our
shoes when we go home if you work with
them etc and we really need
catalog and characterize them so again
that isotope of plutonium last twenty
four thousand years and it is less
radioactive immediately less radiations
per second to use a sloppy term there
versus other isotopes of plutonium that
have much shorter half-lives so we kind
of need to know what are these materials
that we're working with same thing with
data is this a social security number or
is this a news story or is this a log
from one of my servers we've really got
to be aware of that catalog
categorization and cataloging so with
that we can still machine these things
you know we've been making sadly nuclear
bombs for many years we are able to
operate in really micromachining
abilities there and quite often we can
use robotics or personal protective
equipment like those bunny suits but
data now so you know it's also so
harmful in small quantities I can't
change my birthday if it gets lost
that's well that's been released and it
has a long hazard life it's the entirety
of my life that it can be a hazard
potentially same thing for my social
security number
you know similarly these things may be
isolated in my mind to prevent their
spread I don't really want everyone you
know just saying hey like cool I've got
all the data to impersonate you now so
you know I I think most of us agree with
that and again we need a catalog and
characterize them as I'd mentioned you
know data has different sensitivity
levels but you know again we can't just
throw all this stuff away and say hey
we'll never touch it it's too sensitive
to work with so how do we work with it
and you know a lot of us do continuous
deployment and automated deployments
similarly there can be workflow
automation you know I've got this data
it's going to run through this machine
learning pipeline but I'm not going to
look at the data
I trust the workflow and I will look at
the results and I can verify that
workflow but I want to introduce this
concept of gloveboxes so let's talk
about how gloveboxes can help us there
with trying to do proliferation or
hopefully data non-proliferation so oh
and actually just for reference here we
see how nuclear materials sometimes D
proliferate luckily in our own country
this is very highly visible plutonium
going to Idaho National Labs to be
collected there as they close down the
Rocky Flats plant so the data material
fluorophore proliferation
can happen a number of ways you know we
don't necessarily have tackers who want
to blow up our data centers and spread
our data but we do have
here's that will hacker data and spread
it similarly accidental loss you know
this isn't intentionally nefarious but
you know we all might have data on our
laptops or USB sticks or something like
that we've seen organizations very badly
damaged in people's lives damage from
those losses you know I think some some
key key breaks that are worth mentioning
are the Office of Personnel Management
for the US government 22 million
employees had relatively their life
story every foreign travel all of their
family and their addresses every place
they've ever lived as well as just
general PII like Social Security numbers
birthdays etc leaked when that data set
was was was hacked yahoo you know if
you've got friends who maybe use Yahoo
you still get spam from accounts with
their same name and other domains and
that's because of Yahoo unfortunately
having their address book yet get stolen
I think that was there's a three billion
email accounts with date of birth email
and passwords from Yahoo in 2013 for
example got lost similarly you know
anthem the insurance provider 78 million
people there these are really big gross
datasets this is at renewable like
incident in the data world so you know
how do we prevent these accidental
losses and terah's kind of attacks if
you will out our data and we have to
walk through - nowadays the regulatory
environments changing unlike for nuclear
nuclear industries that have the
price-anderson act that says yeah you're
responsible for only a fixed amount of
money and after that well the government
will take care of it yeah you just keep
operating don't worry about it yeah
fault doesn't really matter we don't
have that you know certainly if you
operate in the EU now with GDP our
that's a significant portion of your
revenue if you happen to follow follow
that you have to be very cognizant of
where your data is coming from now if
you want to be able to mix it because
you have to be able to forget people
similarly there's data sovereignty laws
property coming about in many many
regions and so now we have to actually
think about how do we keep data isolated
to where it came from this is much the
same as source control and nuclear
materials but we have to think about
that in in our data sets and a lot of
this you know similarly you must move
the computation therefore which is a
challenge now a lot of us if we use
Hadoop infrastructures or or other
systems we can very easily move that
computation
but a lot of this is beyond the scope of
glovebox it's an already well handled in
the literature we have technologies to
prevent data swamps Apache Atlas is a
technology that aims to provide data
lineage for example and data masking
abilities with Apache Ranger and these
are are relatively well known but they
aren't the full end end philosophy of
how do I interact with my data you know
we we know clean up is messy
for these data sets and we know that
even if we know all of these things you
know I've got my data masked ok great my
data scientists may not be able to
accidentally leak that data but now how
do I control the infrastructure on which
they run on I know lineage I can verify
where this data set came from we had
much of that at Rocky Flats when they
had a fire in 1969 that spread plutonium
over the Denver area this is a picture
of their cleanup so how do we how do we
kind of envision what one of these
Hadoop clusters looks like if we don't
run on one today it's a a nice Network
stack with a couple different
technologies we've got a Apache yarn
which offers resource management so I
can actually move my compute to my data
we've got a patchy HBase which allows me
to store my data in a nice controlled
database Cassandra similarly can run in
this ecosystem very easily and I've got
HDFS the Hadoop distributed file system
which is a cluster spanning file system
to make sure that my data is a
universally accessible and then this all
runs on various worker nodes that
actually do my computations store my
data and some really key things for us
to start thinking about is well how do
we make this glovebox how do i isolate
my data how do I actually you know
validate where my computes coming from
and so let's take a look at three of the
protocols here we've got a rest protocol
for being able to submit applications so
yarn is able to allow me to do job
submission job status job log query and
actually look at the UI of my
application and some of this is really
critical to being able to build a
contained infrastructure now I can
actually say hey I've got one entry
point to be able to make sure that an
arbitrary application being run by a
developer they can't leak stuff out
through their UI because I've got a
central point there similarly I can make
sure that the logs have a maximum size
that I'll return you know maybe you can
tail your log for so much data but after
that we don't want to allow data to
escape
incidentally and then similarly
submitting the code and such that's not
the the scope of a day to drop glove box
but but at least now I can make sure
that the codes coming in HBase for
example has a different protocol and
this one's kind of interesting we'll
talk about why a protobuf remote
procedure call protocol is a little bit
more challenging than a restful protocol
if you're just using commercial
off-the-shelf technology to try to
implement a Dropbox and then we see that
HDFS has a restful api and again HDFS
also has a protobuf api but the
difficulties in an opaque bespoke
protocol make it a little more
challenging to deal with so for the sake
of a drop box using the restful api is
really helpful and we can see just to
kind of get get some ideas here around
what the methods might be here on the
HDTV method yet I can open a file a
really key part is I can get the
checksum of a file so I can validate
what data I put in and if that data
matches what I thought I put in
similarly I can put data into into the
filesystem that's always useful it's
nice to be able actually store the data
and I can append data into the file
system so these you know standard REST
API so standard HTTP verbs here get put
post and so now the question is you know
do i implement a love locks by just
locking everything down you don't know
you can't access it well it kind of
defeats the purpose I want to be able
manipulate my data I want to see my data
and ideally I want to actually get a
work product out from this you know
certainly the Rocky Flats installation
our nuclear arsenal has has been
distributed so there was change in
process controls to be able to move the
material out despite guard towers barbed
wire I think actually tanks were there
which was kind of just odd but
regardless they were able to move
material out so how do we do this if we
is a glove box so that lock everything
challenge everything down challenge we
have firewalls that's common in any IT
shop any any network we're gonna be
operating in but those firewalls have
limitations firewalls can look at
protocols we can have deep packet
inspection but we don't want to just
lock things down we do want to allow
permissiveness with user IDs perhaps and
with the actual context on the requests
certainly encryption you know certainly
at rest encryption on the wire
encryption is rather key and something
that's provided out of the box in many
many stacks HDFS for example
authentication that was key
and this is one thing that I think a lot
of folks if they move to AWS or your
Google compute how do you do
authentication for your users that's
great you've authenticated your services
that's great you might have it talking
to a single sign-on provider on the
front door but how do you pass that
authentication through your stack to
make sure that you know where those
requests came from and then similarly
limiting client connections so I want to
make sure that anything running in my
ecosystem is limited on what it can talk
out too because just yeah I've made this
this glove box everything's right you
know if people have their hands in there
and they're manipulating my data and
then they submit their code and it just
talks to Google and puts it on paste bin
well that kind of defeated the purpose
you know that that was not what I wanted
to have happen so I need to limit
outgoing client connections as well and
I want to motivate kind of an easy entry
point to this with a Dropbox and so what
is a Dropbox well it's kind of on the
periphery of this lock everything down
mentality data can go in and you know
you can put data in say through the HDFS
REST API but I can't get it back out and
so this is really useful for your data
providers you know hey we've got a
website it has social security numbers
and it's generating them left and right
you know people keep enrolling in our
health insurance or whatever your
industry happens to be but you can
append that data but you can't read it
back out if that's compromised for
example that store is safe those
credentials aren't aren't allowing it
and a lot of technologies have this my
sequel as well you can implement similar
things but often we find in practice
after a breach these weren't done this
way similarly I need to provide
validation to transmission and this work
gets a little harder some of the
semantics with HDFS being able to give
me a checksum on the data that was put
in is really useful
I didn't say hey I've got a local copy
you know whatever I uploaded
double-check that what I uploaded is
actually what I thought I uploaded cool
now I can destroy my copy because I'm
positive that handoff was successful and
in our case you know does it operate at
the petabyte scale and luckily for us
HDFS does so what does this look like
well that REST API is as relatively
straightforward I can do that put method
to make a file as I mentioned and it
does a transaction to be able to tell me
hey I've got a metadata server or the
HDFS name node as it's called and I'll
send it to an HDFS data node now I
upload my data and it distributes nicely
you know similarly I can try to download
a file and so I'll say hey I want to
open
file and again it'll do that same
redirect than the metadata server will
say yeah go talk to this machine you
know now I can download and then that
checksum and the checksum is a key part
here so there's a number of different
checks of algorithms provided but I can
get that back out and I can validate the
data that I actually put in so if we
want to implement this as a Dropbox
though normally HDFS allows two-way
access you know otherwise would be
really difficult to build a cluster on
this if it just out of the box know you
sorry you can't read any of the data you
put in and luckily it's relatively easy
to implement the HDFS protocols I said
can either be RPC and that that presents
a lot of challenges most commercial
office often off-the-shelf technologies
don't know that bespoke protobuf RPC and
they probably aren't designed you know
to work with protobuf or cap & proto or
any of these serialization formats but
rest is really common and luckily it
happens to follow a servlet based design
for its rest server so we can actually
do a typical filter on that rest server
and and then it gets handled to their
hand into the request handler which is
the web HDFS interface and so if you
haven't seen a jetty based web service
or a tomcat based web service before the
diagram here kind of gives you an idea
you've got a client and in the last
slides example was just curl at the
command line it talks to an HTTP server
that's really fast moving the bytes but
it doesn't really implement much of the
logic and then I've got this jetty
servlet container which has all the
logic and that's where we we're
concerned about because we need to
implement some extra logic there as I
said authentications key so one of the
things that HDFS nicely provides is a
Kerberos authentication stack so that
everything can be can be kerberized
across the cluster and in particular now
I can get a username I want to motivate
a concept called the drop box filter
here which will actually implement our
ability to write and not be able to read
back and then furthermore I provide that
user info continuing down the stack and
the typical web HDFS logic so what does
it look like when this fails so if we do
a client request without authentication
you would normally get back and looks
like slides have slightly moved around
but regardless you'll see that you need
authentication required in the blue box
there you know you get a nice 401 it's
typical HTTP is has been around on the
web for for 20 years plus now but now if
you also do the request to read
something back you'll get a 403
authentication authorization
authorization failed and you'll be told
that hey you can't actually read that so
this works out nicely we can actually
implement a Dropbox here and we have
code one nice thing at Bloomberg we try
to do a fair amount in the open-source
community so you can actually download
this if you have a Hadoop cluster feel
free to download it let me know where
there might be bugs and you can build
this and drop this onto your own how do
you cluster so let's continue on down
this path though of data drop boxes
while researching this talk one thing I
ran across for years we've been using
this term internally of a data glovebox
folks usually stared at me strangely
unless they knew nuclear material in
Italy so you know kind of nice to be
able to explain that to them finally but
turns out the social sciences have had
this problem for quite some time social
scientists have said hey you know Census
Bureau really want to do something on
current census data and that's really
sensitive so what a lot of the social
sciences have come up with is a concept
called a data Enclave usually this means
somebody goes and sits in a room with a
locked computer that's you know largely
won't allow them to do anything other
than look at the data and they've maybe
a notepad that you know personal read on
their way out and we kind of think of
this as the pain here of these folks who
all three have personal protective
devices they're wearing leaded aprons as
they I think we're actually assembling
plutonium pits before it went up a
dumbwaiter to the shipping department
interesting aside plutonium is
pyrophoric it bursts into flames
spontaneously when trying to find
pictures it turns out that and I think
2003 when they're trying to disassemble
this assembly they hadn't really thought
about the fact that it was vertical
instead of horizontal and they're like
yeah burst into flames again was the do
you report that was kind of disturbing
to be like again and they're like this
one was a little bigger but it was okay
we controlled it and then there was
another later do you report and they
explained yeah it had 15-foot flames but
it's okay
no one got burned in it it was just like
I'm so happy this thing's going away but
regardless we don't want our data
scientists to have to tolerate the same
kind of constriction that these folks
were going through and so that data
Enclave concept though well you say
tends not to have a concept of being
able to have a production pipeline
implemented in it it tends to have this
very centralized model which by since
Cynthia had work was called the curator
model it restricts access
operations and results and it's pretty
draconian about it and furthermore that
curator must remain present throughout
the lifetime of the database so that
means that you know if somebody's today
doing joining Social Security numbers
with billing records or something like
that that's fantastic but that workflow
and a curator model would have to be
explicitly known by effectively a system
operator that beat me in my case and I
don't want to know about data access
patterns that extent we've got 5,000
software engineers they're going to be
doing all sorts of stuff just don't have
time for that so we got to find a more
automated way to do it now data enclaves
as proposed by by Lane and ship at least
we're a little more open being able to
say hey you know let's let's make sure
that we have direct and exact access and
let's make sure that we allow arbitrary
computation and so that was definitely a
very useful thing and and actually some
other key parts direct and exact access
is a very key thought here and
especially if you're trying to implement
something like say billing again often
there's statistical data controls where
I can say you know I'll return the data
but I'm going to fuzz it a little bit
and that works great except for when
you're trying to build customers they
really don't like being told that you've
spent around this much money just pay us
that much anyways so you know we need to
find something that's a little more
precise than that and the arbitrary
computation again we want our data
scientists and our data engineers to be
able to do the best that they can so we
can't constrain it
so again motivating this isolation glove
box technique is is key here we actually
see a man on the the left is
manipulating plutonium with his hands
directly but he you can see that he's
looking through a window there that's
leaded glass to present the radiation
from affecting him in his face as nearly
as much and he's using leaded lead lined
gloves to be able to actually manipulate
that and we can see that the process
control has scaled off quite large at
the Rocky Flats plant on the right
there's tens of glove box gloves to move
material throughout the production
pipeline and to be able to unstick
things as well if you know some some
stuff needed to be cleaned or otherwise
moved around and for us at kind of our
scales right you know if you're running
a Hadoop cluster and you've got hundreds
or thousands of engineers on it you've
got to make sure that you've got
automation in place you know in their
case they had conveyor belts and I think
one of the greatest terms was the one on
the right the chain mayor which happened
to move materia
throughout the plant for us that's the
same as running workflow automation
tools like Apache
Ozzy or running Jenkins for continuous
build and continuous deployment so with
that let's try to kind of walk through
and draw the analogies between that
glove box and what we have
so that letted plane of glass really
needs to provide our data scientists
some way to see the data some way to
actually interact with the data but not
to be able to take it away not to be
able to be contaminated with it we don't
want it on their local machines we don't
want it to be in their home directories
on some Sun box that's outside of that
that data glove box and so this is often
a remote desktop without download
features we want the glove of ports you
know how do we actually make sure that
they can again manipulate that data but
it's not on their hands you know it's
not in their github repos or
what-have-you and that's usually the
arbitrary code execution so you know we
need to run code to manipulate it this
can be a slight change because they
might be used to using Excel or other
other desktop tools and that can still
be implemented in the billeted pane of
glass kind of area we do need robotics
either way we need to be able to do
deployment because you don't want your
data scientists and data engineers being
able to probably talk to like a github
repository directly that would be again
a great way to exfiltrate data even
accidentally and then similarly for
routine operations you've got data
coming in and maybe you need to batch it
up into monthly or weekly files and
whatnot pass throughs in the glovebox
methodology where a way that you'd move
material down and isolate the amount of
material at any one station we have the
same thing firewalls are insufficient
you can have that protocol aware deep
packet inspection as I mentioned but it
can't parse a lot of protocols and so I
can't actually be sure like it's clay
accessing data slash temp through or is
you know junior data scientist who may
just not have as good of procedural
controls accessing temp foo similarly
the rule list becomes exponentially
large as you get more users so it
doesn't really scale similarly databases
tend to be great pass throughs if they
have sufficient authentication the
ability to actually select limit selects
or limit updates and then you have
firewalls in the data glovebox world
different than our IT world which ensure
user and workload isolation so this is a
key part which means that if I write
something to the distributed file system
somebody else can't read it who maybe
doesn't have my project permissions
because we don't want to risk the
contamination of data on that file
system same thing for local file systems
and this starts to become quite a
a thought experiment for a Systems
Administrator to try to think through
where all is the data moving when
somebody does this computation and then
similarly processing you know how do I
actually make sure that an application
is running and it's not open in a
network port that somebody else then
opens and accidentally or intentionally
connects to and data flows that way one
of the nice things is we're using apache
yarn the first two are relatively well
handled by the fact that it actually
makes a new directory for every
application that it's running and then
it destroys that directory on completion
and that directory is only readable by
the user who ran the application so this
helps limit how much I have to chase
down at least so kind of looking at that
leaded pane of glass we want to avoid
overexposure to our data and in doing so
we can we can do that by that limited
RDP often you can set in a Windows
environment to say hey you can't use
copy unfortunately it also means you
can't use paste which is really limiting
for for trying to actually do any
development certainly no file sharing
and no no ability to download files so
again you have to worry about local
files on your your remote desktop system
you know I can't copy something if it's
a Windows box from sequel and you know
slash Windows slash temp if somebody
else wrote it and then you need to have
that isolation for users for that reason
and it's useful to have tools you really
have to think through the tools you want
to provide not luckily the execution
paths but the tools such as dua provides
Jupiter and Zeppelin notebooks you know
do they need to SSH connections to the
cluster directly do they need a JDBC
client and now we kind of motivating on
to the moving on to the glove ports and
robotic side of things you want to
manipulate your data with code so how do
you do that and with apache yarn again
you can use sequel with apache hive you
can use python in scala with apache
spark one nice thing is you can actually
arbitrarily run code and kubernetes is
much the same as apache yarn for a lot
of its primitives so for the most part
this works out very well
you can autumn do animation apache is a
long-standing workflow management engine
in the Hadoop ecosystem and it'll allow
you to for example automate those hive
and spark jobs but some really nice
things is you've got to decontaminate
your results when you want to get it out
of that glove box so what you can ensure
is that maybe a roll account that
doesn't have a human behind it directly
able to log in runs a newsie job that is
that says hey you know we're going to
actually make sure that any data that
has a lineage with any of these files
can't go out of the cluster and if it
can go out of the cluster we'll move it
to an outgoing directory that's
permitted it's been decontaminated
similarly like I say it can run
nonhumans service accounts to be able to
move that data for exfiltration but one
really nice thing too is slowly growing
the ability to do deployments so
recently it acquired a get action so you
can actually point oszi to a git repo
and say hey I want that on HDFS so with
the pass throughs kind of negative
pressures really required when you're
handling small fine-grained nuclear
materials kind of a data we it's also
required we need to make sure the data
moves only in the secure direction
without explicit action making it work
the other way so again you need to
provide the pass process for data
handoff through an environment and this
can be a challenge some techniques that
we use our project directories for
example so that way each project is well
isolated but how you actually limit so
that one person is only in a persona of
one project at a time or that projects
can cross really it's still a challenge
firewalls again you know they're mostly
layer for tcp/ip devices so we kind of
have to throw them out you know you can
man in the middle SSL traffic and things
like that they can actually inspect and
just say hey I don't recognize this
protocol and close that down so they can
still play a role but for the most part
we need something better and we'll
explain how Apache yarns given us some
better user level controls for that so
we we need to make sure that we've got a
drop box for HDFS and that drop box
filter provides us we can get data in
provides us that ability and like I said
databases can offer this as well so you
know for example if you've got a my
sequel database you can make it a drop
box with a grant for insert only for a
user or you can make it only readable
it's kind of funny because we're trying
to isolate data but it's a really useful
thing to have endpoints on your network
that are only readable so the inverse of
the drop box here if I've got a my
sequel database and it provides lots of
reference data you know Wikipedia corpus
may be vital statistics from the
government you know just whatever
whatever interesting things you might
need in your your line of business you
want to be able to read those you
probably want to have to work on them in
a data glovebox type of lockdown
environment but you need to make sure
whatever the data glovebox talks to it
that it can only read otherwise it's a
risk of exfiltrating data that you
haven't
vetted and otherwise made sure about
similarly to those workload and user
isolation firewalls we want to make sure
that our data doesn't spontaneously
combust cleaning up chips was always a
problem for Rocky Flats
you get those little plutonium shavings
and they'd again bust a burst into
flames so with data though it's much the
same you know oh hey yeah that's right
we had a data scientist working on this
project he left this file around you
know hey we had another data science
project we cancelled it but all the data
is running around over here so you
really have to think about how do you do
permissioning on data sets in our case
we have chef that operates on our
clusters and it goes through and it
actually applies the file system
permissions every time those machines
are cheffing which is every five minutes
per machine to make sure that should
anything have accidentally gotten
changed even though we try to design it
so that it can't be it gets set back to
the proper permissions
similarly keeps a log of that so things
are getting changed user collaboration
locations again we've got project
directories and things like that but you
have to figure out how do we want to
actually have our data pass-through and
a lot of this is line of business and
and company specific but then temporary
and failed job data is a big problem so
on the HDFS for example the Hadoop
distributed file system is what Apache
hive the sequel layer will use and I
might say I want to join two terabyte
data sets well that could result in
quite a large data set so it'll start
writing data out to HDFS and maybe
halfway through the user says you know
what this is taking hours I don't want
to run this and cancels it you've got to
make sure that all of your processes
will clean up their temporary data or
wherever they're writing temporary data
to gets cleaned up automatically for you
there's temporary data locations like I
say so hive can do that the hive
warehouse slash temp on in and how deep
distributed file system can be just a
dumping ground of all sorts of insanity
so you have to figure out ways to design
your system so that they don't have
these it is possible to run a Hadoop
cluster without slash temp I definitely
advocate it if you've got a bunch of
data there and then local file systems
as well you know if you're running a
Hadoop cluster as well the users could
be writing code that might be writing
stuff to slash temp slash VAR temp or
dev shared memory so how do you clean
that up so kind of all the trash and
certainly hopefully we can do much
better than they did for Rocky Flats
apparently the story here where this man
is not wearing a bunny suit or anything
and is dumping 55-gallon drums into an
unlined pits hanging out in the middle
Idaho they were like yeah we really want
a limit exposure so the fastest he can
dump the material the better and then
they came back and realized oh yeah when
you dump a bunch of 55-gallon drums they
get beaten up and leak a lot that didn't
work real well and this great quote from
Idaho National Labs was the Department
of Energy now considers Rocky Flats a
triumph in the cleanup program but much
of the waste generated at Rocky Flats
site isn't cleaned up it's here in Idaho
so unfortunately we'll have to deal with
this yet again let's not do that with
data private temporary directories are a
great way to not have to worry about
that the Linux kernel has something
called namespaces user name spaces and
the Pam pluggable authentication module
framework provides a namespace module so
one of the nice things about a Linux
kernel namespace docker for example uses
them to provide isolation is that I can
now take part of the kernel the file
system is what we're most concerned
about and I can actually say that for
you know this user that user another
user they all have different views of
what their apparent file system is and
with the PM namespaces plug-in we could
do that so that the initial mount
namespaces it would be called you can
see that there's a slash temp it's got
inode 100 that's the file system
identifier for that directory we can
know there's a poly instance or poly
instantiation directory that is created
here with some interesting directories
that are also called temp in these cases
with different AI nodes and one of the
key things here is that named space
module for Pam can say when the clay
user logs in ya overwrite that temp
directory basically do an overlay mount
that he can't see at the kernel level to
be able to take his temp clay directory
and actually make it his slash temp
directory so now the user doesn't have
to override any environment settings any
environment variables as far as they
know they just have a completely empty
temp directory and everything that was
working with either the initial mount
namespace you know maybe some some
daemon services the root user they have
their temp directory that's still
co-located but everyone else is isolated
similarly that poly instantiation
directory is usually permission that
zeros all across so no one can just CD
into that directory and read read each
other's temp directories you can do this
also with VAR temp and dev sh m and if
you'd like to see an example of that
again the open source code we have
there's a pull request into our chef
repo on how to implement this so so we
still need to keep the pipes flowing
luckily ours don't have the plutonium
but in the data how do we isolate yarn
and one of the key things here is the
code that's running we have no clue what
it is we don't want to have to have clue
what it is because the data scientists
they're they're prolific there's only so
many of us on the Hadoop infrastructure
team but one of the key things we have
to think about is they still have to
talk to the network so yarn has
implemented a feature called
in yarn 74-68 that actually provides for
yarn to make sure that all of the
traffic from every container that it
spins up not docker container in this
case just yarn cgroups isolated
container actually goes through IP
tables or the host-based firewall one of
the great things about this is there's a
mapping rule so I can say hey all users
you know or each user has their own net
classifiers it's called or net CLS and
the kernel and all groups you know it
may be this group for this data project
or that group for another data project
have these other net classifiers so now
there's still manual work involved but I
can set my IP tables firewall up to be
able to say hey you know user a can only
talk to database a and B should user A's
application try to talk to web server
say it'll get a connection refused
they'll just pretend that that doesn't
exist on the network and similarly one
of the key challenges here is of course
user B would have the inverse mapping
but this is still a distributed system
how do you that HDFS for example Hadoop
distributed file system is running on
multiple machines and it's network
access so I have to think about how do I
set my firewall rules up so that user B
for example can access web service a
that it owns but also talk to all of the
HDFS data nodes can talk to its peers
should be a spark job where spark
launches network services that a spark
executor needs to talk to its peers to
get data so when you write these
firewall rules best practices definitely
have to kind of still be come up with
for this and if you're on the kubernetes
ecosystem it's also possible to
implement this look into the container
networking interface project calico is a
great policy control layer for
kubernetes that can implement similar
functionality so with that firewalls are
important this is from a different fire
the first fire picture I showed you at
Rocky Flats and turned out that they
gutted their building pretty good really
seen plutonium again let's not do this
and let's just kind of walk through
again what what the primitives are here
we've got a leaded painted glass that
remote desktop without coffee download
with user isolation to allow our
developers to at least have a reasonable
development experience the best we can
offer we need to have loved ports some
way to manipulate our data at an arm's
length you know we got to make sure it's
still not something that they can drop
on their machines we need to have some
robotics still in there you know an
infrastructure team endeavoring to do
this has to think through processes and
procedures and how to actually make
those easy to work with for their data
scientists and we need to pass through
how do we actually have the negative
pressure to keep all the data going into
the glovebox and only with extreme
intention leaving the glovebox and the
user and workload isolation firewalls to
make sure that we can offer this as a
multi-tenant environment with multiple
data sets so with that thank you guys
for for listening and you see here I
think I've got slide o up so if anyone
has questions we can walk through them
[Applause]